now they're back here at home after
seven years of research trying to figure
out how to make it all work that huge
project we've been talking about at
tropicana and i-15 it's about to get
rolling and our hector mejia is there
live right now after you had a pretty
in-depth conversation with endot about
this
we did but first off nate check out this
glorious sunrise this morning just puts
you in a wonderful mood even if we're
talking about traffic and road closures
so check out tropic county here this is
the road that leads up to the bridge the
tropicana bridge over the i-15 will be
demolished and rebuilt higher so will
the flyover ramp the problem is ndot
says the bridge over the i-15 keeps
getting hit by traffic another issue
they're trying to solve is the traffic
jams we see here along tropicana so they
shared with us a second simulation video
it shows the future traffic flows once
the tropicana and i-15 interchange gets
finished by november 2024 now currently
we have minor lane reductions that are
only during the overnight hours but the
major construction will begin in the
summer so in the long run it will allow
for future widening of the i-15
something critical as our population
only gets bigger ndot says they're
taking away stop lights they will
reroute dean martin to go underneath
tropicana a little bit closer to the
i-15 and here's why
it creates just terrible terrible
backups removing that signal um
and rerouting dean martin so that it is
a through street with just uh connector
roads up to tropicana where they'll be
right in and ride out only
so as the project ramps up ndot says
they will have hotlines set up in case
anyone has any questions you know the
i-15 the busiest highway in the state
and we also have t-mobile arena
allegiance stadium really close ndot
says are working with agencies to
minimize the traffic impact and back out
here live they say they're also working
with nearby businesses including that in
and out burger we know how busy that
area gets with a lot of carts they're
trying to get their delicious burger so
they're working with them to make sure
the bridge doesn't cover any of the
signage here along tropicana reporting
live hector mejia live local now